On September 30th, Udacity is going to launch it's very first biology
course, Tales From the Genome, a collaboration with the personal genetics
company 23andMe. Now months ago, in preparation for teaching this course,
I created a mini-lesson and shared it with my colleagues here at
Udacity, to see what it would be like to teach genetics
to the world. Now, although the style is a bit different than
what you may be used to in a Udacity course. Because
I created the whole thing on just my iPad. It still conveys
the excitement that I hope comes across in the new
course, Tales from the Genome. Now, if you're not a registered
Udacity user yet, and you want your progress for this
mini lesson to be saved. Then follow the links in the
instructor's notes on this page and create an account, signing
up is free, the lesson is free, the whole course is
going to be free. And I really hope you enjoy learning
how to extract DNA from strawberries, in your very own kitchen.